[Music]
the title is a result of the
geopolitical dimension of resilience
taking center stage in our second annual
foresight report with this report we ask
ourselves what it means to take the eu's
open strategic autonomy and the global
leadership to the next level in an
increasingly multiple global order
we looked at four structural mega trends
that will have a significant impact on
the eu on its path towards 2050 namely
climate change and other environmental
challenges
digital hyper connectivity and
technological transformations
pressure on democracy and values
and shifts in the global order and
demography
we have identified 10 areas where eu
action could enhance our open strategic
autonomy and global leadership giving us
the best possible chance of achieving
our long-term policy objectives like
reaching climate neutrality by 2050
[Music]
all eu actions across the 10 identified
areas are interconnected
for example to ensure the health of eu
citizens we are building a european
health union that invests in health
workers innovative care models and new
technologies
to ensure this is sustainable we need to
secure sufficient supplies of
decarbonized and affordable energy but
also over critical components without
creating new dependencies on raw
materials
[Music]
strategic foresight involves exploring
scenarios identifying trends and
emerging issues using them to steer
better informed decisions and acting in
the present to shape the future
foresight is not a crystal ball however
and we cannot know exactly what that
future might hold
but with a better understanding of the
mega trends at play and the related
uncertainties and opportunities we can
make more ambitious strategic choices
today in pursuit of our global
leadership as we head towards 2050.
the strategic foresight reports will
also inform the annual state of the
union addresses and the commission work
programs
[Music]